let's go next to our caller from the
four four three area code who is calling
today from four four three hello David
yes hi this is Alex from Baltimore
Maryland how are you doing today good
thanks for calling in can you hear me
okay can hear you fine all right cool
just making sure I know you get a lot of
issues with that we do so I was just
curious um when I talk politics with
anybody I usually try to figure when I
figure out which side if they're left to
right I try to find an issue where that
they might buck their own trend so to
speak yes no I was wondering if there's
any issue no matter how insignificant or
minor that you see at least but that you
see kind of from the right-wing
perspective are you all progressive all
the time no matter what no listen I mean
there are overlaps in the sense that for
example there are left libertarian and
right libertarian ideas where there is
probably more common ground
ideologically than some people might
concede although sometimes it's in like
the implementation that there becomes
more of a difference so I am against any
regulation that is not a necessary
regulation to ensure the proper
functioning of society and industry so
like that sounds libertarian the the
problem is I would drastically disagree
with many right libertarians about what
the line is for what's necessary right I
would want way more regulation than they
would but at least the concept I I share
particularly as like a social
libertarian I think that on the issue of
let's see I'm trying to come up with a
better example I agree with the idea
conceptually that if taxes go too high
the economy will start to suffer but I
would completely disagree with people on
the right as to where that limit should
be I think the top marginal tax rate
should be in the low seventies percent
for income above somewhere in the range
of 5 to 10 million dollars so I agree if
you go to high
then you hurt the economy the people on
the right agree with that we just have a
complete disagreement about where that
line should be said so yeah I mean I
don't know I guess there there are some
general areas where I agree with a
principle that might exist on the right
but would vehemently disagree about the
implementation of it gotcha
that's interesting how nice to hear your
take and I got a another minor complaint
if you have a minute I heard on one of
your shows that uh you think granny
smith apples are the only apples that
are worth while I would have to say
first of all how dare you right I'm just
kidding I would implore you to try a
pink lady and pool or a summer summer
Rambo Apple you've never had one of
those I've never had a summer Rambo Pink
Ladies not bad so I should amend my
prior statements Granny Smith apple is
basically so I will disclose I don't
like apple pie I'm not in the pie space
and I particularly don't like apple pie
I don't care about pie period unless
it's like a sweet potato pie okay granny
smith apple is the best apple for almost
all functions so if you just want to
have an apple by itself a nice tart
Granny Smith is the best if you want to
slice it up and put peanut butter on it
a granny smith apple is the best the
exception is if you're putting pieces of
apple in oatmeal and you're cooking it
with the oatmeal and the milk there the
granny smith apple actually isn't the
best and I would go with some version of
a red apple in that case yeah I guess I
was just uh breaking your balls but it's
a very very seriously I appreciate the
phone call thank you so much I hope to
hear from you again